well Black Friday sales are expected to
hit a new record this year 71% of
Americans plan to shop over the
Thanksgiving weekend they are expected
to spend more than a trillion dollars
this holiday season for the first time
ever spending will increase an average
of 310 dollars per shopper from last
year CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with more on this so
Jill consumers are ready to spend money
this holiday season especially this
Black Friday weekend I'm wondering if
what they saw happen on Wall Street and
this continuous sell-off we've seen
there is gonna make them think twice
though I don't think so I mean we've got
a very strong economy we are on pace to
have the best economic growth this year
since 2005 you know unemployment it's at
a 49 year low which is pretty amazing
down under 4% and we also know that
people are feeling pretty good we have
some confidence indicators that we're
sliding just to touch in the last month
or so but overall people feel good
that's why they plan to spend more money
again we should see sales up probably
about four to six percent from a year
ago what to wait to see what the the
ultimate numbers are but I think this
should be a very good season Jill I was
shocked to learn that 89% of the
shopping that's going to be done
tomorrow is going to be done in stores
it has been a tough year for
brick-and-mortar what's bringing people
into the stores people still like to
touch and feel and I really think this
is important when you look at the
retailers that have done really well in
adjusting their approach to consumer
habits they are using a blended approach
they're saying come in the store have a
great experience then you can buy it
online through our website and they're
using that approach to bring you in
there are of course some retailers that
are not faring as well we know she that
that Sears is in bankruptcy and so this
season could be make-or-break to see
whether someone will buy some of those
stores or the name-brand we also know
some other companies are under pressure
JCPenney it's down the stock is down
nearly 60 percent from a year ago
Hudson's Bay is a Canadian company they
own Saks Fifth Avenue and Lord and
Taylor down about 30 percent from a year
ago watching these stores very carefully
so where should consumers look for the
best deals this holiday season I hope
you say Guitar Center
are you yes you know I think that we
have to do our homework and and look I
also have to say I'm a certified
financial planner I don't want to be a
buzzkill but they do call me buzzkill
Jill please you're not a spelling around
here girls don't spend so much money
download a bunch of apps be really smart
there's shop euler their shop savvy
there's great extensions for your
browsers like honey this will help you
collate the best deals arm yourself with
information
don't go nutty expecting that your tax
refunds gonna pay off your credit card
bill and really enjoy the season don't
judge people who shop on Thanksgiving by
the way maybe they don't like their
family judgment exactly you don't need
that fender stratocaster Vlad Wow
okay it's always never buzzkill to you
it's great to have you okay